and then they'll be like this one really
nice joke but there'll be like two
people on either side of the theater
that will just crack up laughing because
they were absolutely on track with it
but nobody else will kind of understand
if you're just a clown Deadpool to not
Titanic all right you're at like an 11
we need to get you down to a five five
and a half tops just phone it in listen
this thing only goes to 11 so beat it
spider-man yeah yeah yeah those are alts
but what's funny is like they put our on
our blooper reel they put alts and an
alter different thing to me Oh God
you look like a house fire was in
another house fire
so there's a lot altered our blooper
reel but I do love I love I'm always
been a big fan of bloopers hey everybody
it's Charlie this is gonna be my video
for all the Deadpool deleted scenes the
extended cut that they're going to be
releasing later this year there is an
actual extended cut that the writers
have talked about because right before
they sent all the different cuts around
the theaters they cut an extra 12
minutes out and then there were stuff
that was cut out earlier either because
it was too graphic or it was too
expensive so if you remember the deleted
scenes and all the band's stuff from the
first Deadpool movie Deadpool 2 has that
in spades so if you're finding me for
the first time
be sure to subscribe to get all the
Marvel videos there's new giveaway stuff
I'll explain at the end of the video
here's where we say of course spoiler
warning for Deadpool 2 if you have not
seen the movie yet we'll be talking
about very specific plot points during
the film but starting at the beginning
of the movie and just working our way
through top of the posters now sighs
from the studio that kill Wolverine yes
tell me that was you well that was a
true story I mean they killed Wolverine
by the way I'm sure upset about that
still because I have my one of my great
goals is to do a Deadpool Logan movie
I'm really really busy doing some stuff
and yeah
you have done give him too much
attention like : the devil escaped from
unicorn Mountain Deadpool electric
Boogaloo yeah
Deadpool suburban commando - we had a
ton of them like honestly a hundred of
them and I think it was just so kind of
amusing to read them all mm-hmm that we
just sort of forgot to actually put one
of them on there probably one of the
funniest things was the ground hogs day
style montage they said got cut out when
Wade first drops down and gets that drug
dealer right after he kills Vanessa so
he chases him down but then you begin a
very short montage of him trying to kill
himself first he stands in traffic and
gets run over by that truck then you go
straight to him sitting on the gasoline
tanks and you start the John wick James
Bond opening credits they had a much
longer version of that Groundhog's Day
style where you just spend a whole
portion of that opening part of the film
just going through different ways each
more graphic than the last of him trying
to end himself they didn't lose it
because it was too graphic they just
lost it because the film itself was too
long and it was slowing down the intro
one of the best things the guys the
early banhammer from Fox was the baby
Hitler post-credits scene so he goes to
the montage of going back in time and
fixing poten quote the timeline he saves
Vanessa
then he saves Peter he goes back into
Wolverine Origins and kills that version
of Deadpool then goes back and kills
himself in real life before he signs the
Green Lantern contract then there was an
extra scene after that where he goes
into the maternity ward of a hospital
and he sees all these babies lined up
and you see him look down oh how cute
and you see a little baby Hitler he
reaches into the baby's bed and
strangles it to death they actually
filmed the scene they showed it to test
audiences but audiences were so freaked
out and didn't know what to think of it
they didn't want to end the movie on a
bummer like that so naturally Fox was
like you are definitely taking that out
of the movie but I would be willing to
bet because they went so far to finish
the scene that they'll just add it right
back onto the DVD there was a hilarious
version of the x-force auditions they
had a bunch of different alternate ideas
for who they could have audition Chris
Evans Human Torch character from the
Fantastic Four movies was probably the
funniest one that they didn't end up
going with
it's catchy right that obviously never
got shot it didn't make it past the
script stage because they wound up going
with the Vanisher and then later adding
Brad Pitt and post but if you guys heard
about black Tom early in the game and
then you saw him in the movie and you
were like how come they only used him
for this racial joke like what was the
deal wasn't black Tom supposed to be a
really big character the truth is that
he was but what happened is is they had
a very juggernaut planned for him in the
film he was gonna be like a genuine
super villain he had these really cool
powers that they were talking about but
they said that the studio looked at the
budget and they said there's no way you
have the money for this so they had to
delete all that material and turn him
into a joke inside the icebox scenes in
they said that the actor was actually a
real trooper about it too when they told
him they're like yeah you know we had
this big plan for you but the studio
said that we couldn't do it he still
came in and shot those scenes but if
you're wondering what his powers are
essentially in the comics it's just
plant manipulation think like a really
hardcore r-rated version of poison ivy
there were a whole bunch of fake scenes
that they shot for those x-force
montages that they used in marketing but
were never in the film Terry Crews said
it blew his mind because they went to
great lengths to shoot very elaborate
scenes that they knew weren't gonna be
in the final cut
there was the scene of Terry Crews
fighting the stuntmen it was the convoy
scene with shatter star fighting the DMC
guards with his two blades then like I
said there was that 12 minutes that they
had to cut out of the final version of
the film part of those were other
separate scenes connected to jokes that
did wind up in the film one of them was
the soap dispenser joke where deadpool
makes colossus think that he jacked off
in a soap dispenser so colossus sniffs
his hands like he had just been using
the soap dispenser and everyone's like
oh that's so gross and so funny at the
same time one of the scenes was them in
the kitchen with Colossus try to pump
the soap dispenser saying it won't work
in deadpool going just give it a few
extra pumps i just filled it there was
another scene with negasonic where
they're in the kitchen and he's just
become an x-men trainee and he's
labeling all of his food inside the
giant refrigerator in the x-mansion that
you see in all the x-men movies and she
just tells him that he's full of [ __ ]
this is all a game you're never gonna be
a real x-man you're just pretending to
do this
probably have that seen back in for the
DVD I know a lot of people were like
where was negasonic she had even less to
do than she did in the first film there
was a little more of Domino showing off
her powers just extended scenes like she
and Deadpool go back and forth about
whether or not luck is a real superpower
even though it's a real thing in the
comics the movie uses it more of a joke
on really funny situations that you see
during action movies where you're like
this could never happen the hero would
never land that shot the way they use
her though is by explaining that it's
literally a superpower which is why they
can have her do all those ridiculous
things so grand total there's about 20
minutes of deleted footage that they're
planning on putting back on the extended
cut and when I set your extended cut the
director did say that yeah we have one
that we're gonna release later they're
putting it together right now just
picking and choosing a lot of its
alternate jokes a lot of its the scenes
that I just told you about but if you
remember the first film like them going
back forth ripping the really funny
jokes some of it will also just be like
that like then just going on and on
trying to improv scenes they don't have
an actual release date for it yet but
I'm assuming it's gonna be later this
year if the infinity war blu-ray and
home video release is gonna be coming
out at the end of July I'd be willing to
bet the Deadpool is just gonna be a
little bit after that but until they do
drop that the giveaway is gonna be for
the infinity war blu-ray so all you have
to do to enter that giveaway is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on the
video leave all your video requests in
the comments below
but click here to watch all the banne
jokes and deleted scenes from the first
Deadpool movie again and click here for
all my Deadpool 2 Easter eggs thank you
so much for watching everybody
awesome I'll see you guys tonight
you